[Musik]
plastik steht am pranger
wir konsumieren täglich so lustig aber
es gibt auch diejenigen die plastik
produzieren und sie schauen wir uns
heute an
[Musik]
wenn sie kurz die arbeit der
kunststofferzeuger erklären den verband
erklären was machen sie was ihre arbeit
wir koordinieren aktivitäten die im
interesse der branche sind und bilden
dafür netzwerke zur umweltverbänden zu
behörden zu ministerien aber auch zu den
partnern die kunststoff verarbeiten
wie sehr wird am anfang der produktion
schon ans ende gedacht also ins
recycling mehr und mehr das war das muss
man glaube ich ehrlicherweise zugestehen
vor 20 jahren 25 jahren noch nicht das
wirkliche thema das problem ist die die
wegwerfmentalität dass die leute nicht
verantwortlich mit den materialien
umgehen und daran müssen wir da hin da
helfen nämlich auch verbote nicht wenn
ich an stelle des kunststoffbecher es
irgendwann ein pappbecher wegwerfen oder
sowas habe ich das kein problem nicht
gelöst da darf nichts wegwerfen und ich
glaube das ist das wo die europäische
kommission dran drehen sollte wir haben
hier einen kleinen netten
experimentierkoffer mit denen
grundschüler schon erste erfahrungen mit
kunststoff sammeln können und um das mal
zu erklären haben wir so einen kleinen
grundstoff schutzhelm hier können sie
ein rohes ei leid tun und lassen es
fallen in den meisten fällen bleibt das
ein ganz wird also geschützt wir haben
verschiedene folien in dem man
materialien einpacken kann zum teil die
sich biologisch zu ersetzen warm und das
kommt in den schulen sehr sehr gut an
wenn man solche freundin sieht und wenn
man dann am strand irgendwo in
südostasien rumläuft nicht in spanien
dann dienen wiederum die können ja
bestimmt nur aus so dass asien
wir haben ja einen intensiven verbrauch
an kunststoff folien in deutschland das
entscheidende ist halt an den strand in
die umwelt gehört diese folie und dieser
kunststoff mit sicherheit nicht aber sie
verantwortung ein bisschen leicht
abgeschafft von dem verband wenn sie
sagen wir stellen nur her wir klären ja
intensiv auf wir haben sehr intensive
netzwerke die wir bedienen
wir machen diese versuche wir gehen an
die schulen wir nehmen die erfahrung und
die wir hier in deutschland mit der
sortierung und trennung von kunststoffen
haben und exportieren die in andere
länder und sagen ihr die technologie ist
da also wir stellen uns nicht
leichtfertig aus der verantwortung wir
nehmen dieses thema extrem er ist okay
okay das ist eine verpackung für
gummibärchen und so eine flasche sind
auch über stoffe drin die gefährlich
sind vor allen dingen wenn das hier zum
beispiel das ist bei einem großen online
versandhändler bestellt kommt vermutlich
irgendwo aus china was ist da drin
können sie das sagen spontan nicht also
wir können diese beiden beispiele hier
mal nehmen bringt wasser oder limonade
ist ein lebensmittel gummibärchen auch
es gibt ziemlich intensiver vorschriften
übrigens nur für kunststoffe was drin
sein darf und was aus diesen folien
rauskommen davon auf lebensmittel
übergehen darf so dass sie mit den
beiden produkten absolut keine probleme
haben die sind sicherer als viele andere
verpackungen die nicht diesem
umfassenden gesetzlichen vorgaben
unterliegen hier wird es ein bisschen
schwieriger bei produkten die im ausland
produziert werden es wird regelmäßig
überprüft was kommt aus asien auf den
europäischen markt aber das sind
stichprobenartige untersuchungen das
kann keiner sagen aber ihr habe ich auch
ein langlebiges produkt das hoffentlich
lange hält schauen wir mal so ein
bisschen nach vorne zu bezahlen das seit
90 1 die masse an verdoppelt hat wo
führt das hin muss man sehen kann glaube
ich im moment gar keiner so richtig in
diese glaskugel hineininterpretieren man
muss ja mal gucken wo kommt der mehr
einsatz von verpackung her
es ist eine wiederverschließbar kite
oder öffnungs funktion die zugeschaut
werden kann
immer wieder dabei das heißt es ist auch
viel mehr funktionalität in seiner
verpackung mit rein gekommen
einzelne fangen jetzt momentan an und
diskutieren auch für lebensmitteln art
von mehrwegsystemen interessanterweise
sind diese mehrweg gefäße die man dann
anbietet aus kunststoff insofern ob es
mehr oder weniger werden wird weiß ich
im moment noch nicht dafür ist dieser
prozess zu komplex aber ich weiß auf
jeden fall dass auch im
verpackungsbereich kunststoffteilen der
lösung sein wird und nicht teil des
problems
[Musik]
[Applaus]